e
all right it being 10 o'clock we're
going to open a work session for
division 3 um we we've got a tremendous
amount to do in two hours so uh we're
going to try to keep things uh pretty
minimal uh but um first I want to tie up
some loose ends from the prior work
session we had a number of bills that we
said that
uh we would accept with an amendment and
we described the amendment uh the
amendment was then subsequently uh
written by
OS uh we haven't formally looked at the
written Amendment so I want to make sure
that I we don't need to go revote the
acceptance of the amendment I just want
to make sure that we T we touch each
Amendment and if anyone objects to what
came out of our you know that something
that came out is different than what
they anticipated that that you have an
opportunity to uh say that so that we
don't accidentally or mistakenly uh
trudge forward when we should not be
doing that so uh then after that we
have um a whole fresh discussion on
596 um there's a um a a revisit on
499 uh representative tersi I believe
put together an amendment and
representative walner is going to to
teach us about it uh and then 417 is a
big issue uh and this is really going to
be an opportunity for represent of ho to
walk us through a a pretty big Amendment
so I I'm I'm going to ask you now when
it when it happens let's let's keep it
moving y okay all right um so with that
going to uh with the um professional
assistance of our vice chair to make
sure I don't mess this up um there was
an amendment for SB
um has that Amendment been distributed
yet Mr
Ripple I've emailed uh to all the
members 352 as well as the other
amendments that were discussed yet not
formally drafted drafted uh I do have
hard copies if you'd like me to hand
those out as well please do hand out the
hard copies but um but you but the what
you emailed is identical to what you're
handing out now it's the same thing
that's correct okay what's the number
I'll start with 352 I think there were
four
bills I think he means the amendment
number to
352 sorry the bill is 352 and the
amendment number is 1915
okay so we're not going to revote these
I I just want to give you enough time to
validate that it's what you're expecting
so that we can just lock it down and
move
on this was a major Bill obviously this
is was about the firefighters cancer
screening
so so I'm going to assume everyone's had
an opportunity to read it and recall
their thoughts from last week is there
any any objection to accepting uh uh 1
1915 as the amendment that we voted
on on the 10th any
objections not not seeing any objections
we're going to lock that baby down
355 is there an amendment on 355 so I I
just mentioned 355 but they're actually
isn't one on that that amendment was
voted on and the committee had a copy of
it on Friday so the next bill I believe
is for 404 4
404 do do we have a representative
wner go ahead you put your mic on though
there an amendment on 355 to change the
date you will have an amendment for that
I don't have it yet my thought was that
that would be a full committee Amendment
since this bill wasn't noticed for
today's work session oh okay even if
okay
was that the cycl magalo virus is that
right yeah what we what we were informed
was by the hospital Association is that
if we're going to do this we need to uh
push back the effective date so that
they have time to actually uh be
prepared to be accountable for it we
can't make them respond to a law that
they haven't had a chance to adapt yes
represent a whole thank you Mr chair is
there any reason we can't just proceed
with right without objection from this
committee to address the date in full
Finance uh I I don't see any reason we
can't do that you know I I I got the
feeling that we're pretty flexible in a
work session I I just ass soon have less
stuff brought into the full finance
committee that we could U have our
position clear on am I am I going to
violate a clerk rule if if we go ahead
and look at that Amendment and then no I
don't think you're violating any rules I
think the I think the division has the
discretion to do that I don't actually
have a hard copy of that Amendment with
me it's still with OS okay all right so
we can't see it but because it's just
not available all right so is there any
objection to pushing out the effective
date through that amendment process so
that the hospital Association if this
becomes law has the opportunity to get
ready to U meet their
obligations I'm I'm not I'm not seeing
any objections so we'll just bring that
up in full Finance later day uh Mr chair
okay um so that brings us to uh
404 4 404 expanding the Child Care
Professionals
eligibility uh we voted otpa on this do
we have have we seen the amendment
you've uh I haven't handed it out yet
I'll do so now it's 19218
represent walner when you're ready
is this the one that was 300,000 and we
thought it
would
no
Milli federal funds used
a big part
of I'm assuming I'm waiting for you
represent wner I I don't want to
pressure
you this was a big one there were a lot
of changes can can you do a quick
validation that we picked up on
okay I can also call your attention to
the changes that it contains I just need
to pull up my notes first all right
that'd be
great do you want me to talk about it uh
sure okay so I maybe Kevin you can help
me be sure I got the right places on
line
15 um we um are using median income
there at one point I think we had looked
at 500% but now it's median income which
is a lot less than 500% of poverty um we
changed a date the date to take effect
on January 1 so you have to go to the
back page page three line
10 um it will take effect January 1 of
20125 so it will be basically a
six-month program until there's a new
budget to consider it in the new
budget
and I think the
other Kevin was the other piece that
they would be allowed to contract this
out I yes yes I think that was in your
previous Amendment so I don't believe
that's a
change
um don't recall where and here that is
page two lines 20 and 21 I
believe if I could it was to be lapsing
where does that appear now yeah um I
don't think it appears but there was
previously non-aps language that's been
removed so it would lapse okay and also
on page three lines seven and8 uh states
that federal funds shall be used first
and any remainder shall be General funds
thank you y and also the reporting
requirement was fleshed out a bit that's
on page two uh lines 26 through 30 you
can see the specific items that will be
contained in the
report any other line items that we
wanted to address and of course it was
changed to project from Pilots I no that
throughout yes that was the main thing
that was the only thing
uh so so with that uh are you satisfied
that this amendment meets our agreement
yes okay so I'm going to um move off of
uh
404 and are
we what about 409 do we have any issues
with 409 9 that was also an
otpa this
Stringham um do we did we see the
amendment last week yes you had that one
in hand okay so there was there was
nothing to reconsider this time
455 uh relative Medicaid reimbursement
rates uh this is one that Mr Litman has
uh come in and uh could you could you
tell us if if what what you you think
you were doing Rel relative to the
Litman email you and I have chatted on
so I think at this point um I've
received no direction to do anything uh
just to summarize what Mr Litman uh
shared with me yesterday he expressed
some concern that by setting the
Medicaid rates for these devices
permanently at 90% of the Medicare rates
uh he's committing the state would be
committing itself to pay 90% of the
Medicare rate well into the future uh no
matter how high that rate may go so as
an alternative he had suggested setting
the rate at 90% of the Medicare rate in
effect as of a date certain at some
point in
2024 um so I mentioned to him that it
might be too late to do that in the
house I'm not sure it's up to the
committee members um and that he could
consider talking to the Senate and
requesting a committee of conference on
this bill if he's so inclined so so my
bias and this is for division three
input and short discussion my bias is if
um if if we get some good opinion like
that and it is feasible for us to go
ahead and and get the paperwork right
that we should do that so that we do our
work before we send it over to the other
body u m m Mr chair Mr Ripple said
Medicare rates it's
Medicaid that that was another
discussion that happened on Friday there
was some language about changing
Medicare to Medicaid as part of my
discussion with Mr Litman yesterday we
concluded that Medicare as the as the
bill came you was in fact correct so
it's Medicare rather than Medicaid right
it would set the Medicaid rates for
these devices at 90% of the Medicare
rate which is probably two or three
times higher than Medicaid it could be
significantly higher yes thank you but
all right I didn't catch that change but
thank you okay so would it even be
feasible to get an amendment from
OSS before this afternoon's full finance
committee hearing I think we probably
could I would want to get some exact
language from the Department either Mr
Litman or someone else just to make sure
that we're getting in exactly what uh
what he wants in there are you are you
able to do that Mr Williams or Miss
Morris I I don't know which one of you
has this
ball okay so so my my preference is we
we go ahead and try to get the amendment
right and get it through full finance
and send it to the floor the way we want
it to be instead of kicking the can over
to the other body is there anyone with a
different
opinion not not seeing any um so
representative Stringham well I also
talked um uh with Mr lman yesterday and
also completed a table of the difference
between current Medicaid rates and the
Medicare rates for every single service
that's eligible under there the typical
difference is about 60% um um uh what
I'd heard and and Mr Litman has CMS in
today and then has business in the
Senate this afternoon so I'm not sure
he'll be able to join us um um uh his
his discussion with the contractor mman
was that that with the $620,000
appropriation um they could fund the 90%
of Medicare rate adjustment but he did
want he did also say he wants to freeze
it the the amendment I'm looking at I
don't think does that so it would still
need to be Mr liman specified that we
should state that uh we would reimburse
it 90% for the
2024 Medicare fee schedule that was the
language I had but I'm not sure that
it's exact so I'm reluctant to go with
that without further input all right so
so I will say the the Medicare fee
schedule does update every quarter not
once a year so oh uh so I my analysis
was on the April 1st
2024 levels so so I didn't know that
they did a quarterly update but we
should probably if we're going to
specify a snapshot we should make sure
we're clear on which
snapshot okay so um so what we just I I
I could take a motion to consider this
amendment and we'll see if people
support the amendment as we've discussed
here I'm willing to make that motion
you'll make it is there a second I'll
second it second I'll
move uh Amendment
1942 with the understanding that there
is going to be a date that is added to
it effective on right the fee schedule
as of and a particular calendar date so
that it is locked down
okay and I don't think I've handed that
out yet I I representative Stringham has
it because we talked right before the
meeting started but I don't think that
would be great let's go ahead and hand
that out thank
you
thanks
sorry two I gave him my one
here okay so I Mr clerk I I think the we
have a motion before us to accept uh
1924 amendment to sp4
55 with uh the appropriate language
inserted into
1924 to reference 90% of the appropriate
quarter 2024 Medicare
schedule is that you got that Mr chair I
was going to say right after on line six
after the word Medicare we we put a date
code of January 1st 2024 I think that
addresses the concern and it timestamps
this to a particular time that the cost
can be figured out and whether it's
January 1st or April 1st right I think
the the marginal change is going to be
minimal but timestamping it to a known
date would be effective I I think that
could be a good thing for Mr Ripple to
consider doing did you hear the
recommendation I didn't I'm sorry okay I
I don't want to tie your hands on this
though because you're in the middle of
coordinating what the language ought to
be but representative whole suggests
that you put the the the timing the 2024
part on line six as part of line
six and and if that works if that works
for you then that's good
yep okay so since this is an amendment
we'll do a show of hands how many
support this amendment as we just
verbally described okay any opposed not
seeing any let's let's go ahead and do
that
um
plus okay so
463 463 was courta appointed counsel I
think there's uh an amendment to what we
voted on last week is
there representative walner U do we have
that
we're on
yeah the the second one I sent you right
yeah that's that's what
m
no this isn't the second one this is the
first one you're right wrong
one oh excuse me Mr
Ripple I I believe this was the um this
is not the most recent
version it was emailed to
us actually we have
a
um a different place gotcha okay oh it
is okay yes it is does this still have
the
14 no not so so this is not the
amendment we agreed to yes yes this
isn't the amendment we talked about last
week this is a new Amendment
okay so the amendment we talked about
last week what amend did we did we
actually have a written amendment that
we voted on last week yes yes we voted
on uh the PRI Amendment 1890 correct and
then we had further discussion what did
we want to do what did
what what what does your Amendment do
relative to 1890 representative walner
well it sort of it it's looks at the
issue of um not having enough attorneys
available it looks at it in a different
way than the amendment we we uh passed
last week and what it what it does is
basically the issue is that on
July 1 of 2025
when children will become eligible for a
courta appointed
lawyer there are will already be a large
number of children in residential
placement that's around today I guess
it's around
125 124 125 children so it means on that
date you'd have to come up with an
attorney for 124
children when you stop and think about
it it is a pretty big amount of
attorneys to come up with that quickly
so what this does is it basically phases
in and you'll find that on the second
page of the amendment it phases
in it phases in the
um the attorneys so that first during
the first phase on July one on July 31st
of 2025
the first phase the older children will
get a lawyer then the younger then 14y
olds to 15y olds on October so it phases
it in so that by the end of the year all
children will have had a lawyer rather
than get hit by that um demand early on
all right so so so my my reaction to
this is that this is substantially
different than what we talked about on
the on the other day and that we voted
on the other day and uh while it's could
be a vast improvement over what we had I
don't think we have the time today to
really get into it so so
I
I I I I'm I'm not really excited about
passing this right now representative
wer do you have a comment it's it still
leaves in section four which is the 14
Child Protective Service workers which
we had testimony that that's far too
many they don't need all those extra
people I believe it uh uh this amendment
deletes well replaces that with the
prospective repeal in section four so
the appropriation and the positions
would not be in the result section four
okay it is they are go
ahead
yeah thank you
all right um do you want to make a
motion on your
Amendment oh yes I move um that we pass
Amendment
28h second
further
discussion representative hle
representative Stringham further
discussion this is uh this is this is
awfully quick I this is uh hitting my
discomfort level with moving this fast
on something that we
haven't had time to pull
apart representative
wer you're all right your representative
priest I think this uh provides us um
with a process that can
adequately support uh providing counsel
to children in need and I think it kind
of phases it in it makes it realistic
and I think we can achieve the same
goals without any cost to the
state for the next
year yeah so my the PO part of this that
disturbs me the most uh at a visceral
level is my reaction to lines 22 to 34
which page on on page two that that
seems awfully prescriptive it it's sort
of like
saying cars should be able to achieve 50
miles a gallon by 2030 it it it it's
it's kind of an aspirational thing where
reality and technology and the like may
not be able to meet that date and
putting it into law I think
is is is inappropriate but but that that
that's my view on that I i' I'd probably
be what would happen to this amendment
representative walner if we deleted
lines
22 through
34 well that's the that's the point of
the amendment is the phas in allowing
for the phase in are you also looking at
the other new piece
um
is go ahead we need we need to look at
that also because if we
cannot accomplish the phase in as
outlined here it does give them
another way of doing it another way of
going back represent Moy so on page two
of the walner amendment starting on line
eight through line 10 the new language
addresses the
scenario that a person a child would not
receive an attorney because of the
shortage of attorneys in New Hampshire
and it would allow the case to continue
despite there not being an attorney
found after a diligent effort to locate
one so that critical language which
satisfies that concern reads starting on
line 8 not withstanding the above in any
action in which despite diligent efforts
to secure councel an attorney is not
available for appointment litigation May
proceed until an attorney becomes
available so so so just to thumb wrestle
words with you uh the the the phrase
that's there is not withstanding the
above the portion that bothers me is
below though the setting out the
schedule is is is below that disclaimer
and I'm not enough of a lawyer and I
haven't looked at this long enough to to
to think if by setting this table in
place if we're setting the state up for
lawsuits if we don't meet them can we
allow somebody to speak Mr Ripple did
you so in an earlier in the draft that
was provided to OS that raised the
begins on line 8 was actually below the
schedule yes um but they moved it up to
this paragraph so it could be could be
worded to apply
to the schedule in section
e i i that that would remove my my
biggest concern is to make it make sure
that that that's sort of are are out if
we need it and I don't want to use it
but I don't want to set us up for
failure either
yes representating walner in in the
draft that we sent to OSS um those words
not with uh notwithstanding the above
were under the phase out okay I can show
you in no no I believe you so so I think
I think we have a a motion to vote I
think we have a clarification to the
motion though because we're talking
about changing this amendment to make
that notwithstanding more
inclusive um and I I would be okay with
with that if the motion were something
like to adopt uh Amendment
1928 with under the condition that the
notwithstanding language on line 8
becomes U comprehensive
for for the for the whole thing and I'm
I'm not going to Wordsmith it because I
think Mr Ripple can do that okay is is
is is that a go ahead represent H thank
you Mr chair um I think there's another
drafting issue um online page one
line um
2829 it references subparagraph 2E right
in in in cases under this chapter
subject to the phase in schedule
established in sub paragraph
2E on page three we repeal that on line
three later on in in life um and I don't
think we want to right I don't think we
want to
leave that section b as drafted with a
repeal of section right of of
subparagraph e later on so I think we do
need to fix how we do the repeal um in
section four as well right I I'm okay
repealing the perspective phase in but
then you got to adjust the language in
28 and 29 that was one did did you
follow that Mr Ripple does that does
that make sense to you what
representative H just said it does make
sense to me I think
I think it might a little while to get
this drafted correctly so it might be it
might be later on in the full committee
meeting before we get this back for vote
but but yes that change makes sense okay
and then to the point that you were just
discussing Mr chairman right the
notwithstanding language on lines eight
and
following um I think it does actually
want to be in parag in ref in paragraph
B that's the appropriate place to leave
it um
repeat it again I think you might need
to repeat it again for paragraph e and
the reason I say that is we're we're
describing what the court should be
doing in paragraph B and that
notwithstanding language technically
needs to be there as a best efforts
paragraph I would propose that we copy
that language 8 through 8 through 12 and
put it in section e as well to write for
the phas in just for for clarity I I
understand what we're trying to do I I
think if if I can speak for
representative walner um I think the
goal is to have that done that way and
that would be the easiest and cleanest
way because we're going to end up
repealing chapter or section e at some
point for this amendment and we don't
want that notwithstanding language to be
repealed in the future okay um could I
have an opportunity to work with the
people who actually worked on the draft
drafting of this and um come
back this afternoon with the cleaned up
Amendment Mr chair yeah if I may this is
actually a fair amount of redrafting is
it acceptable that we take the first
five minutes of our 1:00 Finance to
actually meet as division
three that gives two hours to work out
the amendment the language and have
something so and five or 5 minutes to
one so I I suggest you I think you're
suggesting we recess to uh
1250 uh on on um this
amendment any objections to that no all
right I'll I'll do that later that
recess um all
right so that was 463
596 uh is something that we want to
discuss in full are there any other
Strays in here where we said that we
verbally we accepted an amendment but we
haven't yet seen the amendment I think I
think we're done
right I don't have any others all right
okay so with that uh I think we've
tightened up our Loose Ends from last
week uh and now let's go back up to
um the Committee hearing or the work
session on S SP
596 uh I I think I may have a an
amendment to that and is there are there
any other amendments that we should
consider as part of 596 I think
representative wal's amendment was
handed out on
Friday yes I see it it was uh
1864 a Very Good Year
yeah
yeah lots of American History all
right so does everyone have their copy
of 1864 from last
week oh if I can borrow one from
somebody yeah I have a couple
extras all
right
please I can't believe you got it done
thank you
yeah grad
1933 so I would like
to um bring up the amendment that just
got to you uh
1933 um and I guess I should have a
motion to
motion sure I would move the adoption of
amendment 1933
H I'll second for the purpose of
discussion all right so uh so let me
explain uh what's going on uh with this
amendment what this amendment takes into
consideration is that there are a lot of
moving Parts in terms of how 596 would
actually get implemented uh we um we
push off from the the dock a bit in
terms in 596 saying that we uh aren't
going we we're going to change the
definition of special needs or at risk
kids um we we state that uh those that
are considered to be at risk now or if
in the risk of in future risk
that uh they would basically um be
assessed or determined to be uh
qualified for this program based on a a
child assessment the the criteria for
selecting the assessment tool is not in
here at all so we don't really know what
we're doing in terms of expanding the
eligibility for this uh this this grant
um the rules
around um who can do the assessment and
what kind of assessment they should
use is is not defined in
596 um if we spend additional money
because we have additional kids that are
at risk there's nothing in 596 that says
how that money would be spent there's
nothing that says
that if we spend this money these are
our expectations of what will happen if
we spend the money if we give you money
what will you do in return for the
additional money that's totally silent
on that and so as I uh was relooking at
this with uh in a conversation with the
Department last night um I was reminded
that the Senate initially had put this
into interim study and then uh for some
reason went ahead and and passed it and
sent us sent it to us as I look at it
it's still not cooked there are too many
details should should we require uh a
minimum of a bachelor's qualified
individual to do conduct the assessment
it's silent on the qualifications of who
does the assessment really should it be
a some people would say no it's got to
be at least a master's trained person so
so I I I would like us to put this into
a study committee this does the study
committee the uh uh it would be composed
of of
um you know legislative representation
to keep it a committee instead of a
commission um but that the committee is
being requested to invite the design of
the DHHS commissioner uh the design from
the Department of Education uh get a
child care provider in there um get the
mental health resource uh in there uh
representative or early supports
representative from the public school
presi grw program and a representative
from Head Start so it it feels a little
bit like a commission without being one
because I think we can get it up and get
it going faster that way so um so that I
I would I would like your support for
this I I I'm I'm not opposed to the bill
but the bill 596 as is right now is just
um got too many Loose Ends it's too wide
open and we don't we don't know what the
financial implication of it is really we
don't know how who the affected
population is we don't know who's going
to conduct the assessments we don't know
which assessments are going to be used
uh we don't know what obligations will
be incurred by the people that accept
the money for the additional population
it's it's just a whole lot of
uncertainty at this point representative
walner would you like to comment
well I'm I'm sort of disappointed that
we're going
from something that would really be
beneficial
to some children in our state who um
definitely need need some additional
supports in order to be in a Child Care
Program um I do want to remind you that
this is not a new
program the department already has a
program like this what it does is it
basically allows
for children with disabil children with
that are have disabilities that are
identified through the through an
assessment tool um the department
already has a verification of children
with special needs that they a child
have that they have to receive from the
provider um the very
ification has to include a
description of um what kinds of things
the child will receive in order to meet
their special their special need um so
this is really just an an expansion of a
program that already exists and allows a
group of children who have the potential
to have serious
um serious
disabilities and particularly I think
around
behavior and we're allow these children
to be in child care with some extra
supports I think at this point a lot of
children who have these kinds of um
issues are excluded from child care and
um this what this bill would have done
is allow a few of those children in this
was not a large number of children and
the program itself the way it is now is
a very small
number are there other comments
representative
whole thank you Mr chair in reviewing
the language as sent over by the Senate
we're trying to use arpa funds to get
this in place with no um effectively no
generals funding used not to exceed
$1 my concern is we start this program
with arpa funds and the next thing that
happens is the arpa funds have run out
and we're back here in this committee
trying to figure out how we're funding
this in the next bium so I think um the
study committee does some of this and we
can make sure that that funding issue is
also part of what they look
into go ahead I just want I did want to
just um remind people that in the
amendment that I brought in on Friday
the um funding of this was for the
Department of Health and Services may
use federal funds where
available and the general funds can be
used that are already in the existing um
budget of this of the uh Health and
Human Services committee Health and
Human Services Department so it would
not require any additional appropriation
at this point and like I said there is
an existing program um I think the spin
down
from what we appropriated in those lines
I think the spin down has been um low in
the
last couple of years actually so there
may be some funds available in those
lines so so would you believe that I
agree completely with your intent but
I'm completely convinced that
596 is not written well enough and
comprehensive enough to be a good bill
so I I I just assume put this into a
study committee so that we do it right
and we take care of this population uh
professionally and
appropriately representa hold did you
have another comment because I I really
want to vote we got to keep going do
what move on we can move on okay so we
have uh a motion to adopt um 1933
Amendment um to
596 are are you ready for
vote oh yeah yeah yeah yeah so because
it's an amendment we can do this by show
hands if you're in favor of that
Amendment please raise your
hand if you're
opposed okay so
um so that's 43 we're missing uh a
republican today and we're missing a
Democrat today so I I I think the
outcome is the same as it would have
been
given the partisan nature of that vat so
um uh is do
yeah thank you for taking my question um
is it is it um in order to to consider
another amendment at this time take
take we're going to still
talk what were you thinking
representative priest um would like to
make a motion to approve Amendment
H okay and we all have a copy of that
that is the walner amendment it was
given to us last Friday okay is that
motion seconded I'll entertain that
motion I'll second for the okay second
by representative hle representative
priest would you like to speak to your
motion or representative walner either
one or both representative priest
starting with you yeah okay um again I
think this kind of answers the question
that was raised that if the funding did
not exist in the current budget what
would happen to this program so um I I
feel very strong that this would add to
SB
596 represent thank you Mr chairman um
unfortunately Mr White isn't here um to
represent the department where they are
financially otherwise I would pose my
question to him but it is my
understanding in various conversations
I've had with him that they are looking
at having trouble meeting the requested
is it Reserve or whatever money that
comes back already and that there's just
not necessarily money in DHHS or extra
money that they can dispose at this
point to get another
program that that's a good observation I
I my observation is that this completely
uh becomes moot if uh my Amendment holds
up if uh 13 1933 holds up then 1864
becomes Moot and I would oppose uh an
vote uh we can do a show of
hands uh on uh Amendment 1864 to 596 if
you're in favor raise your
hand uh if you're opposed raise your
hand the amendment fails
uh so we need an otpa motion on 596 so
moved uh with uh
1933 yes all right is there a
second second okay moved in second Mr
clerk when you're ready we'll record a
vote the bill is 596 the motion is a to
pass as amended the amendment is 1933 H
um uh representative Mooney yes
representative hle yes uh chairman Wier
yes Representative walner
no um Stringham votes no Priest No and
chairman
Edwards uh yes motion passes four to
three go on to
finance okay we'll we'll bring that to
the full finance committee um so a lot
of people just walked in is there a
spokesperson for for yall to kind of
introduce what's going on hi come on up
use the mic tell us tell us what we're
doing
here yeah you you hit the little button
and and it
turns hi I'm Crystal O'Brien I'm the
librarian at conquered high school and I
have with me some students um in grades
9 through 12 um in journalism class
actually two journalism classes and they
had the opportunity to interview some um
State reps earlier this morning and um
we got permission to Eve stop for a
little bit and experience this um so if
it's okay we'll just stay for another 10
minutes or so and then we're going to
walk back to conquered High School okay
well you're welcome anytime this is
Eevees dropping it's an open public
session this this kind of thing that the
public is welcome and encouraged to come
participate in anytime um because we
believe that's so strong we also do Zoom
so if this fascinates you so much that
you must have more of it we actually
have a zoom channel that has
pre-recorded stuff from old meetings and
and then we broadcast live and archive
those as well so we want to be open to
the uh public for that um is it did you
say something YouTube oh is it YouTube
yes it is YouTube I think they that uh
it's not Tik Tok but it's still okay um
all right well welcome thank
you all right um this is this is a this
is a work session this is a little
different than many of the hearings that
you might go to most of the hearings are
by policy committees that take a look at
a new bill um and determine whether or
not they want to support the policy then
it comes over to finance after the house
passes it Finance figures out
how how the finances would work we
usually have a public session where we
get smarter we invite people to talk to
us and then we do a work session where
we determine amongst the committee
members what how we want to pursue a
bill so uh so that's what today is today
we're not really looking for public
input to this process but we're we're
conducting the meeting transparently so
that folks know what we think is going
on so with that I think I think
we're
at Let's do let's do 499 next uh because
1417 I'm not sure how long that'll last
um is there a new walner
Amendment and then I think there's I
don't know if there's a new wner yes
there is is there a new a whole
Amendment are you going with what you
had
oh excuse me I'm on 499 sorry on 417
there is a minor tweak based on the
feedback rev relative to Kin and
effective kin I tweak the language there
um so there yes there is a new Amendment
but IT addresses the concerns expressed
during Friday's exact session all
right so so where did we leave it on 499
499 uh the the the division voted it out
basically uh stripping most of the the
provisions of 499 and keeping in place
an amendment that instead just focused
on adding um uh changes to the senior
eligibility system so that they
could um have their uh authorization
last three years instead of one and the
like uh with that was Amendment
1650 uh the torki amendment 1917
does um more than that and since
representative tki could not be here
today I think representative walner is
going to speak on her behalf one one of
my first questions for you would be
representative walner um is is this this
is meant to replace completely the
amendment 1650 or it's meant to
supplement it to replace okay the uh
part that we that was voted on by this
division
Vision last week I think it was is on p
on the second page um line
24 I I see it on I see it on the first
page on lines
15 through 18 the elderly s yes and then
again on um on line 24 yeah okay so so
this so This does everything we said we
do and now you want to talk about what
else it would do it would as everyone on
the division I'm sure remembers this
would add back in the additional funds
that would come from the federal
government to families through their EBT
um card it um they call it summer EBT
it's for CH it's to help families um
have a little extra money and this is
not a lot of money but it's meaningful
if you're a very low-income family
so for the summer I believe it's
$120 for the summer so that's about $10
a week per
child um that would this would be
available and I think you have to
remember who we're talking about these
are extremely low-income families who
need additional
funds to purchase food every month of
the year not just the summer but this is
what is available um New Hampshire is
not doing this at this time but has done
it during during the pandemic so um it
would end up bringing in for these
families about
4.3 million million dollar in EBT
benefits significant amount of money in
New Hampshire um to provide food for
families um because a uh little birdie
told me maybe the way we should look at
this is to look at the
appropriation by um categories so that's
why you see the
appropriation somewhat different than we
usually see Appropriations usually we're
seeing Appropriations just one big lump
sum of money and that's the way it came
but this breaks the appropriation down
um and talks about how much is for
personnel how much is for the EBT cards
um how much is for technology so the um
cost of the program is broken out in
this amendment that's the major reason
the amendment looks as long as it does
but this just and but the amendment
itself adds back in the summer EBT
program uh thank thank you for that and
the one of the reasons um for full
disclosure that that I was willing to
reopen today's work session to uh for
$499
was um because the I spent a good deal
of time with the Department the
department um uh supported to them from
their perspective how important this is
the um they they pointed out that if if
if we take on these one-time Investments
that uh that that will set us up for
about $4.6 eight million a year in
federal money um and and so the the
money that's going to the food is
actually federal funds that get
transferred onto the EBT card but we
have to get ourselves administratively
ready to handle it that that initial
amount of money is well over a million
dollars but it would pay uh get paid
down basically as an investment each
month that we collect uh the sumary EBT
program
um so I went from being um completely uh
opposed to the rest of 499 to to
becoming um where I can see both sides
of it and uh uh and and I I I have to
say what bothers me about
499 is that in
2024 we're going to be unable to get the
money to the kids and until October and
and I think just from a program
professionalism saying that we're going
to take care of food insecurity and
hunger in the summer but not deliver on
the delivering the money until October
is is we're over
representing the contribution we're
making and and you could shrug and say
well it's better to get the money later
than never
uh that's sort of I think the the
Judgment there um but uh but getting it
right before a general election coming
from the federal money that that sort of
reeks a little bit like politics to me
Federal politics but still the money is
for the kids um so so I could shrug on
that too um and and with this investment
uh it's there's going to be a little bit
more money needed for the investment in
the next budget about 780,000 but once
that investment is in place it should
generate about 4.68 million a year so um
so I don't know that's a fairly good um
contribution like if you look at
Medicaid what is it we we we do a 5050
match sometimes we do a 6040 match in
this case it would be like a a
2575 match in effect so I I as far as m
relative matches go I I I'm I'm it's
probably as as good of terms as we can
get representative Mooney do you have
comments this is a very sensitive
subject it is very sensitive no one
wants to see anyone be hungry go away
hungry I do have three specific
questions if it's in order to perhaps
have someone maybe Miss milin come up
and answer them if not I understand this
is a work session not a public input
session uh I would like to discuss those
so so who would you like to have come
forward I think Miss um
Milligan are you would are you willing
to come talk to us okay you have our
invitation at this point just thank you
Miss milikin I really appreciate you
coming up here I'm sure this wasn't
expected but I appreciate you uh doing
this my questions are this now this is a
summer
EBT hunger program summer different from
school year different from after the
Bell different from free and reduced
lunch so my questions are these number
one what is the security in terms of
being sure the child receives the food
in schools naturally we are sure that
child will be fed there's plenty of
supervision in a school building that
that child directly receives the food
I'm curious how that works in the
summer second question where does the
child obtain this food during the summer
once again in a school year we know
exactly where it comes from and we know
exactly where it goes I'm curious how
that works now in the
summer number three what is the
oversight to see if this is working
specifically
what percentage is wasted what
percentage is nutritious what
isn't are the portions
sufficient who oversees that who
monitors that to report back that this
investment was wisely made and that
there is a you know a report on it later
on of the things I mentioned so those
are my three very directed questions
thank you very
much so because this is a work session
focusing primarily on our own dialogues
let let me take a hack at at about the
first two questions and then get ready
to correct me uh and then be prepared to
answer three Prim number three p
primarily um okay so so this summer EBT
program as I understand it is an
enhancement of the uh SNAP program which
provides EB cards to to families and
they get money um from that card at a at
a at a fixed rate the burden on that
snap fund is reduced in in effect during
the summer because the kids are getting
supplemental food so so although the the
the basic snap funding doesn't change
year round the demand on the family
snap budget goes up during the summer
relative to the school year because the
kid is not being fed at school so so
what this program is intended to do is
to take that snap card and enhance the
amount that the federal government puts
on that EBT card uh during the summer
months
to help address some of the incremental
change in the family's demands during
the summer because they don't have food
available through the schools so it's
it's so the card is in the possession of
a responsible adult uh in in theory and
that the responsible adult is using the
EBT card properly you know in theory to
to buy food at grocery stores and the
like and to prepare the food at home or
wherever um so um so the snap program
basically is is the summer EBT program
with kind of a bump up of $40 per kid
per month during the summer uh that's
the way I understand the summer EBT
program have I mated any of that so
you're absolutely so I'm Laura milikin
from New Hampshire hunger Solutions
thank you um you have stated it
absolutely correctly for families that
are already on
snap um the summer EBT program is
available to any uh child who is
eligible for the free and reduced lunch
program during the school year and some
of those kids are not on Snap so
families who are not on snap um can
apply through the department to receive
vote funds they would get an EBT card
which works just like Snap but it's not
in fact a snap uh EBT card but it works
just the same it's only um able to be
used on
food um so and those dollars you know of
course are spent um at local grocery
stores and New
Hampshire do you have comments on on
either response to the first two
questions and then the third question
could could you read what you think the
third question is and address it so I
believe it was about oversight and
whether the program is working is that
the is that the
question uh to clarify yes oversight in
terms of right is the program working
with regards to um minimal waste the
portions being efficient the food being
of a nutritious
value right so um the nice part about uh
an EBT card uh in the snap program or in
the summer EBT program is that families
can make the choices that fit their own
food needs um including their cultural
needs including their uh Health dietary
needs um and so they families make that
choice at the grow grocery store um so
it's you
know there are programs where you get
whatever uh is on offer um at the pickup
and this is able to be um tailored by by
the family to meet the child's actual
needs thank you again for well I just
want to thank Miss Milligan again for uh
coming forward and being so informative
throughout this process thank you thank
you representative thank you Mr chair I
have two questions
for Miss milin I do if she would be
willing to take these so one is relative
to the restrictions on EBT card use for
instance if it's in if it's under the
control of the parent could they buy a
case of cocacola or a bag of chips
versus buying something in the dairy
aisle is there any restrictions on how
these cards are used when it falls under
food food is broadly defined
so I think um there are not restrictions
on uh the kind of food bought as long as
it is food it cannot be alcohol it
cannot be cannot be diapers um it must
be food okay um and you know to uh
to uh representative Mooney's question
these are a tiny number of benefits so
families are making the choices that
meet their needs from both a health
perspective but also a Financial
perspective if I only have a couple of
dollars a month that I might choose a
big bag of chips instead of something
healthier because it will go further
okay um second question right this is as
the chairman had said earlier this is a
program where the funds won't be
available until the October time frame
based on the current
implementation what is the is there
anything that would restrict us from
trying to implement this during next
budget cycle since next summer would be
impacted directly
anyway are
there uh and and you you you'll have a
chance to respond I I just wanted to uh
point out to representative H that his
thinking and my thinking on this have a
lot of similarities and I went down the
same track and I I'd been probing the
department on uh how much would we
reduce from this investment if we only
focused on
2025 if we if we went ahead and said
look we just can't do a professional
program in 24 that delivers on any
promises that are going to get
made kids are going to be hungry in the
summer expecting to get money in October
it it just is not a good way to do
business so I tried to carve off the 24
piece but it had a relatively
inconsequential
impact on the money needed to invest to
get ready for
25 that I rationalized we may as well
keep 24 in there as well because we're
we're spending the infrastructure to get
ready in any case um I just um so to me
it was a tradeoff it's not good it's not
attractive it's not anything to be proud
of in terms of of great implementation
but I think it does deliver a little bit
more money to families that could use
some food assistance that that my that's
my position or what I'm thinking I could
I could argue the other side of it on
depending on how grouchy I am but so
representative or Excuse Me Miss milikin
do you want want to comment I agree with
what you said
um the bulk of the costs are one-time
costs and they're required for 2025
yeah this is over a million in setup
costs and this population should already
be qualified for other programs so this
is a an addition to programs they're
already qualified for to ensure they get
fed so it's it seems like we're spending
a million dollars setting up a program
for people that already have provisions
and and like my town we have the town
sets up a program for anybody that's
hungry and especially in the summertime
there's a lot of fresh produce available
that gets distributed through the food
pantry so I'm I'm not in favor this I
think it's an extra program that does
very little because it spends a million
dollars to put people in who are already
already eligible to be fed and gets
spends more money thank you all right um
so we're still talking about uh
Amendment
1917 if there's no further discussion I
would like to uh go ahead and recess
s499 so that uh we we each have an
opportunity to caucus and come back when
when we when we recess and come back
we've already talked about uh picking up
the walner amendment to
463 I'd like to have us ready to just
vote it should take three minutes to
vote on the amendment when we come back
so I'm I'm going to go ahead and recess
499 um with a a a vote on this amendment
um prior to the 1:00 Finance meeting
thank thank you so much representative
PRI yes are we going to go back to SP
417 yeah no we're about to just start it
right now thank you for the
clarification all right so excellent
segue give give them what they want and
so we're going to go ahead
and um
representative we we have at least what
two amendments on 417 we have uh two
whole amendments plus one other or I'm
only aware of the two there was 1889
that was discussed on Friday and there's
a replacement for that
1923 so it it's my understanding you
want to withdraw uh 1889 from
consideration correct and that your new
amendment is is very similar and
captures some of the comments made made
in Committee hearing last week that is
also correct all right so as Mr Ripple
hands it out um representative Lon did a
great job summarizing the changes caught
90% of them but not necessarily all of
them um some place it was a merge of
just at a high level of the Senate bill
that came over thank you for
coming and representative wier's
Amendment merged together with minor
changes
um and I will quickly run through these
right um line page one line six it went
from less restrictive to leas
restrictive you guys discussed that um
this leaves it where it is in current
law it does add here that and there's a
minor change on lines 13 14 from what
you saw on Friday because we flipped
judicial oversight and written approval
The Way It Was Written was the you
needed written approval of the judicial
branch as well as approval of DCF this
is just right o increased oversight by
the judicial branch written approval by
DCF um this was discussed on Friday no
changes here in lines 24 through 31
right it changes the default that this
person hasn't been charged with any
abuse or neglect they are deemed to be a
fit parent the presumption is they are
innocent um however the department can
challenge that if they believe they have
sufficient evidence um minor change from
district and family to just Circuit
Court to be consistent with our statutes
it does change the definition sorry the
standard of evidence to being clear and
convincing evidence from the
preponderance um otherwise there's no
changes there I apologize I'm running
through this really quickly page
two you know just I I I I do think you
have some time so so don't let's let's
go cover page one were there any
questions on page page one before I jump
to page
two it sounds to me like you captured
the feedback from the other day so
represent Mooney thank you
representative pole the whole uh
preponderance of the
evidence where does that appear in your
Amendment that's lines 28 and
29 of page one page one
okay may may I make a observation on
these l
this was discussed last week uh we were
told that the standard is a
preponderance of the evidence as opposed
to clear and convincing evidence clear
and convincing evidence is tends to be
more of a of standard Ed in criminal law
and this is this is not that this is a
form of civil procedure um I I I I was
um affected by that comment a little bit
and and as I got to understand uh other
uses in New hampsh law of the term clear
and convincing uh there are other areas
where we do clear and convincing like if
there's a judicial review for uh
issuance of a marriage license between
somebody uh 16 and 18 they must provide
clear and convincing evidence that there
is is is nothing wrong in that
relationship so I I I think we've
already established a precedent for
clear and convincing and and my concern
about changing preponderance has changed
I I I I support your language okay
um the case law is the evidence is
highly and substantially more likely to
be true than untrue and I think if we're
trying to take and prevent children from
going out of state and we need an option
in state and we need a parent or a kin
or like kin or all the other
combinations um there really needs to be
strong evidence that this family that we
would want to put the children with is
not suitable and clear and convincing is
is a standard that I think is
appropriate um it gives us a a it makes
it more than more likely than not we'll
find an easier way to keep the children
in state in their in their Network um
potentially in the same location or
relatively close and and we were trying
with this bill not to ship as many kids
out of state that was one of the goals
so
um any other questions on page one or
I'll jump to page
[Applause]
two seeing none page two the changes are
on line five and lines 13 through 18
rela this is I adopted representative
wier's Amendment but I made changes on
line five instead of the unique needs of
the child I specified physical mental
emotional and medical needs which was
part of the discussion when we had met
the prior time and then I
um representative Lon covered this well
in G the change was relative to the
parents cooperation with the
Department's assessment instead of being
a punishment toward the parent be an
encouragement for them to cooperate with
the Department in terms of sharing
information that um a parent who's
cooperating with the Department um that
will be seen as a factor in favor of
Fitness of that parent um and then a
small clarification on the fact that a
parent owns a firearm shall not be made
make a home unsafe normally weigh
against the parent I did discuss this
with some and
if for those for those who are listening
online I'm handing out a copy of um RSA
650-e negligent storage of firearms
right concerns were ra raised relative
to what happens with a parent who may
not be taking care of their firearms
um and we do have under our criminal
code negligent storage of firearms law
laws and I think that adequately covers
any of the issues that were raised to me
privately behind the scenes relative to
the language here so I do believe that a
parent who owns a firearm right that
doesn't make the home unsafe right that
shouldn't be used against them
carelessness is already a criminal act
that's a different story that would
probably meet the burdens that we're
talking about separately so I don't
think that language is is um over the
top in any
way uh then the next change is down
online
29 right this was the kin effective kin
whatever it now has been replaced with
with a related adult or kin and kin is
using the definition of
170-25 um Roman numeral 8 and that was
replaced twice in this bill to address
that the judge has some discretion
here what is the best option with the
available list of adults or families
that would be to help take care of the
child so it might be a related adult it
could be a biologically related adult as
well it could be kin it could be a great
uncle or it could be um the neighbor who
happens to spend a lot of time with
these kids all the time and that is a
related adult and if the judge makes the
determination that staying in that in
that same neighborhood with the neighbor
who he's always over that kid's house is
the best interest of the child type
thing it it's there um on behalf of some
members of the committee I think we're
done with the concept of fictive Ken
okay thank you and then I I lines 27 and
28 this was covered on Friday there's no
changes here right contrary to the
welfare of the child that's more of a
federal standard relative to various
benefits and we're in keeping with
consistent with federal law there
um again we referenced the 170 e25
language um
right later on and
[Music]
then
um this is basically the rest of the
amendment is the same Mr Ripple did I
miss something in terms of the
modifications I would just point out not
to revisit the kin versus fictive kin
issue but all references to fictive Kin
have actually been removed from this
version not just the two that reference
the statutory definition specifically
yep so that was it um it was a minor
list of changes from
priday um so okay so did if folks had an
opportunity to read representative
Hall's initial Amendment and we just
went over the variations from that
amendment to this amendment um are there
questions about either these variations
or his initial amendment that he he
offered last week representative Mooney
thank you Mr chair thank you
representative hle uh the amendment uh
to me looks good however on line 2829 of
page one that
changing from prance of the evidence to
clear and convincing I don't know if
there's anyone who could maybe make a
comment on that I mean that is a huge
shift it might look uh very simple on
paper however that is
big thank you for the question I'm not
sure if there's anybody who can speak to
it we have an attorney in the house we
have at least one what are the odds that
we would have an attorney here we have
two actually
um Aon do you want to speak
I from a state's persp perspective what
do you what do you think the impact of
the shifting of the evidentiary standard
would be hi introduce yourself good
morning eron crean general counsel for
the judicial branch uh both preponderant
of the evidence and clear and convincing
are commonly used evidentiary standards
that you're going to encounter
throughout the RSA uh clear and
convincing is the standard that we use
for many of our bail determinations for
example if the clear and convincing uh
evidence does not exist the person will
be released uh so this is a this is a
common standard but it is certainly
higher uh many of the other
determinations that are made with regard
to child's welfare are made by
preponderance of the evidence uh so this
will be a change to a higher standard
but it is a standard that the courts
understand and Implement in other
circumstances as well because it's a
higher
standard do do you think it would be
reasonable for the legislation
legislature to assume that this might
result in in fewer REM removals of
children from families you should
absolutely expect a difference as a
result of a change in this standard all
right do you think by changing the
number of removals uh reducing the
number of removals do you think we would
be incurring signif it's hard for you to
forecast this but would but but the
trade-off there is would we be assuming
uh increased risk to this uh population
as a result of having fewer removals and
how would we describe that risk it's
difficult for me to say how many cases
would be changed by the move of the
standard um this is a balancing act that
the legislature does in many areas for
example by bailing more people under
clear and convincing rather than
preponderance there is potentially a
risk that they reoffend um but the
legislature has struck a balance that
they want there to be a high standard
for for bail determinations a higher
standard than preponderance so so this
is a fascinating thing you're pointing
out the analogy here so uh bail now is
written that um you can
only require bail if there's clear and
convincing evidence that the the person
in custody is a threat to themselves or
to the others is that is that how that's
used there's a slight difference
depending on what the the factors are
whether you're risk of flight versus a
danger to reoffend but for most
determinations it is clear and
convincing that due to some bail reform
from a few years ago so so clear and
convincing is an appropriate standard
when we're adjudicating whether or not
somebody should be getting bail or
released it it is the standard that is
typically used for so Society has
accepted the risk associated with that
higher standard you here you're you're
balancing um the risk of potential
offense by the parent and also the the
interest in keeping the parent and the
child together that's a very difficult
balance it's currently struck a
preponderance of the evidence the
legislature could certainly balance that
differently and say that it needs to be
clear and convincing all right
representative H give it back to you
thank you thank you Mr Gan for for those
answers I think part of this is the
motivation to make sure we're trying to
keep the children in state at be as best
possible and the standard for
effectively termination of parental
rights could be things as clear and
convincing and
um preponderance of evidence is the
least is the least likely right it is is
more likely than true meaning 51% clear
and convincing is a step above that the
highest standard is reasonable doubt
we're not talking about Beyond A
Reasonable Doubt level language um all
three of these are used in both civil
and criminal level statutes I do think
moving the bar up a little bit is
beneficial in our society and that's why
I made that
recommendation I I feel uncomfortable
going to clearing convincing I think
we're talking I mean this is very
different than talking about bail I
think this is um in some cases very
young children that we might be leaving
at risk and I certainly would not I
would not um support clear and
convincing thank
you how are you feeling about the
amendment overall if it remain
preponderance would you support the
amendment other than that aspect of the
amendment or is that just one of several
things are we going to look at uh
representative wiers or is
that so the two have worked together and
I think representative Wilder's
amendment is in
here not going to look at it separately
if representative wer wants us to we can
I I don't see a need but no I appreciate
him incorporating it was just a couple
of places it talks about the uh idea
that having a gun does not make make you
an unfit parent and also it was
um trying to remember the other place
was it it was line it was line five
right you shouldn't have to go to a
hearing if there's nothing against you
you shouldn't have to go through a
hearing to to uh to find out you're
innocent I I I'm just saying I'm just
thinking now that in these last two
bills there's been a a presumption of of
whether whether or not parents are
trustworthy uh in the EBT question uh we
we believe parents are trustworthy when
they get the EBT to spend the money
wisely to allow the the food that they
can purchase to be dedicated and and
help their children more than themselves
which is a selfish potential for an EBT
card feed yourself and not worry about
your kids it doesn't fix the neglect
issue but we're still giving them more
trust by giving them more money and in
this case we're we're saying that you
know if we go with the clear and
convincing we're saying that we've
decided we want to trust parents uh if
we want to trust parents then we should
make sure that the state has a high
standard for interfering with a family
in a way that can destroy it so I I I
I'm I have become very comfortable with
clear and convincing but if I may right
this entire section of law in n in RSA
in charge of them because of an abuse or
neglect case and we want to find an
alternate parent as soon as
possible we should make the roadblocks
to that alternate parent as little as
possible doesn't mean the department
can't continue to keep an eye on them
there's a lot of other things that could
go on but I'm trying not to make sure
I'm trying to make sure these children
aren't shipped to an out ofate
facility representative Stringham yeah I
guess I guess I I fall down um in in
line with the propond preponderance of
the evidence as being uh appropriate in
this case um I think it's very difficult
for um uh people who are charged with
you know coming into an extremely
difficult situation like this to put
together a legal case a CR essentially
criminal level of evidence uh that abuse
is occurring a lot of emotional abuse uh
abuse with very young children is is
difficult to to make clear and
convincing uh but uh they still um May
reach the conclusion that in the best
interest of the child um having the
child uh leave the uh leave the
household that they're in is in the
child's best interest and uh I feel with
with the evidence level of preponderance
um more likely to reach uh the correct
conclusion there um you know part of the
rest of the the amendment I'm not
uh I'm not really in favor of the the
firearm provision uh there's a lot of
things the fact that a person owns a
swimming pool that is not covered uh
shall not make a a home unsafe the fact
that uh they have a balcony uh with
steep stairs should not be uh weighted
against the parent I mean you could put
a thousand things in there I don't think
we need to uh include include uh this
this one thing uh you know that uh
uh that obviously a lot of people have
concerns about um the um and they don't
need to have a a criminal violation of a
gun law um you know shouldn't be
required to be considered if guns laying
around the house and uh uh loaded uh
when they happen to visit that would I'm
sure that would be a consideration as
would uh a large number of other unsafe
uh circumstances in the house so um I I
just I just think that that one sentence
is gratuitous in this bill
so uh the decision is going to be made
very arbitrarily or
subjectively by some State worker they
don't they don't even know the
difference between clear and convincing
and and a preponderance they're just
making their own decision on whether
you're a fit parent or not and you you
would have to take them to court to say
how did you make that decision you won't
know it just somebody that's working and
that division of Children and Youth is
has made the decision whether this
parent is unfit and I don't think they
even care whether these two uh whether
it's preponderance or clear they're just
going to make their own decision so so
what is your position in or out on the
changing the change you don't you don't
care no I think clear and convincing is
is adequate all right
all right
uh okay I I yeah representative priest
yes I also have a concern about the
change from preponderance to clear and
convincing and I think by raising that
bar up we are and we will be risking the
lives of many children
how many children what
percentage sir I don't know I don't have
the statistics in front of me so this is
a a concern this is a concern okay this
is a concern all right but we I don't
want any more cases in the paper where a
child has been left with their parents
and abused and probably killed so should
we take all par kids from their parents
should we presume all parents this this
is not what we're talking about sir I'm
talking about the change that's been
made in this
amendment you are but you're you're
creating I weigh to the lives of the
children that's involved and protecting
them as much as we can and you think the
state is in a better position to do that
than parents yes the state never makes
mistakes the everybody makes look at the
YDC law everyone makes mistakes and and
and the state is not perfect nobody's
perfect sir so so shouldn't we default
but I think the state have
have represent priest we're just having
a conversation we are too just just the
tone just a little just calm the tone a
little please we can have the
conversation Mr chair if I may yeah
maybe this will help I'm looking at a
court document I can get this printed
out for everybody if they want um
guardianship of a minor general
information
in there this is relative to
guardianship of the person Rel okay and
I'm going to quote the entire paragraph
at the hearing it will be the burden of
the person seeking the guardianship over
the person of the minor to prove by a
preponderance of the evidence that the
guardianship is in the best interest of
the minor if however the person seeking
guardianship is not apparent which is
what we're talking about here we're
talking about others okay the person
must prove by clear and convincing
evidence that it is in the best interest
of the minor we're already using this
language in these stat that we're
talking about in our current court
procedures I would argue we're talking
about parents that okay we're trying our
best to make sure the child is not
shipped out of the state we need an
alternate location because we know that
there's abuse or neglect well we presume
that there's abuse or neglect going on
because the child has been pulled from
the parent okay the court now has to
figure out where they're going to put
the child that is this that is the
section in this flowchart we're dealing
with and we want to limit as the speed
bumps or minimize the number of speed
bumps to get that child out of this
family that was abusive to some other
rest location and not Warehouse them in
a hotel or in a group home we've seen
the horrors that happen when these kids
are not in families and we want to move
them there as quickly as possible the
state better have really good evidence
that they can't move them there before
they say no this is not acceptable
that's why the standard was put in place
I I I think this is actually a better
option than the for bonance of evidence
and I think with the goal to get the
children to a new location this is the
best thing we can do sorry a little bit
emotional I'm looking for further
discussion if not I think um was there a
motion on this I forget did we and we
have we been in a discussion I will move
H first and second Mr clerk when you're
ready
oh oh this is an amendment so we can do
a show of hands anyone object to show
hands on this okay show a hands if
you're in favor of amendment 1923 please
raise your
hand if you're
opposed it's uh
43 I think that would be um the same
result had we had full attendance this
morning so um so I think we're now ready
for
are there any other amendments other
than the wer Amendment because we
decided we're not going to take on the
wer
Amendment okay so if there are no other
amendments we're ready for an otpa
motion anybody made it uh are you going
to make it no I I will I will make the
motion ought to pass with Amendment 1923
H second second person seconded when
you're ready for a
vote Senate bill Senate Bill 4177 as
amended by um Amendment 1923 H the
motion is ought to pass as amended
representative Mooney yes representative
Hull yes chairman Wier yes
representative W walner
no uh representative Stringham votes no
representative Priest
No chairman
Edwards yes thank you for your work
representative h
um at this point uh I think we have
concluded this morning's uh business
with the exception of um I think we
wanted to do a recess uh and come back
at I'm going to make it recess to
12:45 on um Amendment
1928 uh to
463 and I think we agreed that was there
another res recess I thought we were
going to recess something else there was
a recess on Cate Bill 455 as well the
Medicaid rates tied to Medicare rates
okay and so we're going to recess on 455
as well we'll be back at
12:45 um to complete the our work before
division or
Finance
e
e e
okay just as a reminder we're coming
back with division three here at
12:45 and then 1:00 is the full finance
committee
e
e e
all right it being 12:45 I'm going to
call division 3 out of uh
recess um we recessed because we wanted
to uh have um an opportunity to to uh
maybe get some amendments written by OS
in record time and also to give the uh
commit division three time to caucus and
so we've done that and uh I'm going to
I'm going to bring back uh SB
499 uh first uh there has been an
amendment that uh passed out of um uh
division
3650 that um that Amendment basically
said that um we wanted to take the part
of 499 dealing with senior eligibility
in their enrollment process funded at
about
37,500 that's that's a recommendation
you would see to that there's been a lot
of discussion uh around 499 on what to
do with the summer EBT program and um
and we didn't take a vote in division
three I don't think we're ready to take
a vote now because representative hle
has yet another amendment to offer on
499 and um since since we can't vote on
it in division three we're going to uh
Mr chair just just ask to arm wrestle it
during the um full
committee um hold on a second so um so
there's not going to be a vote on on 417
out of division three the discuss 499
thank you so much we're going to we're
going to defer that and talk about it in
full Finance um after uh he gets a
chance to describe what his Amendment
does yes represent respectfully Mr
chairman no you don't have to be
respectful just tell well you asked for
it
yeah I wanted to thank you for bringing
499 back up for discussion today and I
apologize I was unable to attend this
morning I was able to listen in two
parts of it and I want to thank the
committee for um taking a look at my
amendment I am however looking at the
clock a little concerned that we're now
going to be thrown another amendment to
full committee without for without a
proper disc discussion and a real look
at it I mean there is a timeline to
these things and I'm I'm concerned that
we're already back here right now so
since we have no time can we seed your
time to representative hle so he can
describe what his Amendment will be it's
so simple I think you can we'll be able
to wrap our head around it uh and and
wait until the full Finance discussion
for the full debate are you are you can
can he take the time
now sure representative H what what what
amendment are you bringing forward so
the amendment um I I saw and we we
discussed um 197h which was
representative Tori's Amendment it
leaves in lines 31 and 32
$667,000 for some implementation costs I
think those numbers are excessive um
based on what I understand about
software
development so the amendment would leave
the 375 in place and then would put um
$50,000 to DHHS to write the appropriate
rfqs to get quotes in to get bid in to
figure out a full project plan to
implement this and to have that
information for us by the end of by
October 1st so that prior to the
deadlines for filing legislation next
year they can in fact have a plan in
place to implement
this and we we already know that this
money would not benefit children this
year
but hold on it is not available until
October the truth is in the middle it's
in the middle the money would be aail
aailable in the October time frame for
the families not available over the
summer even if this was passed as is so
this kind of is one way to look at
trying to get this done for summer of 25
but not try and do it in an off budget
year so further discussion I think
should wait until we actually see his
Amendment
um I'd like to just clarify one thing
that was said yes it is not true that
they will not see that money this year
obviously if this goes into effect I
believe the date is like July upon
signing July 1 there needs to be those
technical updates to be done the monies
that the families would receive for
those children will be delayed that is
true however to say that they won't
receive these funds this year is
incorrect and it would be leaving $4
million on the table
so I can tell you that I would not be
supporting that Amendment so what
representative whole wasn't completely
without uh truth because um we would be
telling New Hampshire that we're making
this money available to them because of
hunger issues in the summer but to hang
on because we can't get you the money
until October at the earliest so it so
it it it it is true to his major point
that uh the program is slow on
delivering the money I think he misspoke
when he said it wouldn't help this year
it certainly wouldn't help this summer
as the point of it so okay so I think we
should uh wrap up that because that's
going to be an exciting full Finance
conversation um and then which one am I
doing
now we we we we recessed around 463
right yes and 4 uh 4
463 um we have um an amendment that uh
is still TBD and a walner Amendment on
463 is is is that has that been
done so I just received one back um that
I asked OS to put in your name
oh that I believe reflects for the most
part the committee's discussion from
earlier although I'm looking at it now
and there may be one piece that's left
out but so the key thing to that was to
make sure that the not withstanding the
above language was copy replicated
appropriately and said
differently said
differently but in any case what are you
you're seeing an error still well so so
let me ask you about that part my
understanding of the
committee's desire earlier was to take
that language the notwithstanding keep
it where it is but also move it down
below the phas in schedule that is what
this amendment would do um it doesn't
address the
part so as representative H mentioned uh
subp paragraph 2E is repealed at a later
date but there's a reference to it that
would remain permanently in statute this
amendment doesn't change that I'm not
sure if that's a huge deal um it's
really up to the committee members is
that from your experience something that
could be addressed in an enroll bills
Amendment later on type thing um does it
fall in
that I I don't want to commit to saying
yes but it seems technical enough that
it possibly could be
okay you want to vote on it do you want
to make a motion I'll move that we adopt
the amendment that um that Mr Ripple
just discussed
[Music]
and um understand that there might be a
a small clerical correction relative to
that one repeal implementation date and
the fact that it leaves it in statute
elsewhere and it needs to be cleaned up
second so we're we're walking closer
we're getting closer do we have an
amendment number for that please it's
it's still TBD I think
1948 is is 194 we're not voting on 1948
right now are we
yeah yeah was that your motion to vote
on on yes okay because I I didn't recall
a
number have one more K if we have an
amendment in front of us we do let let's
go ahead and point out in the that this
amendment complies with what we agreed
to in division three or it differs from
what we said
earlier Mr chair um I'm speaking to
Amendment 1948 and for the purpose of
make a motion to adopt 1948
H okay all is there and then then this
is what you seconded representative
Mooney yes okay so since it's an
amendment if you're in favor of this
amendment raise your
hand if you're oppose the amendment
raise your hand it passes so I need an
otpa motion I move OTP um for Amendment
2024 1948 H relative to Senate Bill 463
the representative Stringham is not
ready to oh there you are good you just
hid so are you ready for a vote on this
I am ready okay would you please conduct
a vote the motion is ought to pass as
amended how Senate Bill
four uh 463 with Amendment 1948 H
representative
Mooney go ahead yes representative Earth
yes representative hle yes yes uh
chairman Wier yes representative
walner yes representative
tersi yes representative Stringham votes
yes representative priest yes uh and
chairman Edwards yes final vote being
90 uh the motion
passes uh thank you and then Mr chair if
I may real quick um Amendment there is
no time but go ahead 1948 H is 1928 h
verbatim with that one adoption of the
notwithstanding language and both of
them still need the clerical correction
which I think could be fixed later on
without it's a minor issue relative to
the repeal
language and just to reiterate the
positions are removed in the ENT
Amendment we just adopted they are
removed thank
you okay I'm I want to bring forward
um we haven't voted yet on
455 uh and there is an wait we did we
had a new Amendment on this it was based
off of
1924 and uh it it changed the Baseline
for the Medicaid reimbursement rates is
is that Amendment available I don't have
it yet I expect to have it shortly okay
but that one I think is fairly clear
it's the amendment that you saw earlier
with that one minor change yeah so so I
don't think that's going to be
controversial in full fin Finance um and
with that I I think we're our recess is
we've had enough
fun okay so sorry for the screwing um
but these we got a lot of bills and
there was a lot of complexity and um we
only had a certain amount of time so
thank you everybody